[Music]
I can't believe P world has blown up
like this I mean this is crazy right
people are saying it's a ripoff of
Pokemon but with guns it's a fun game
people are saying it's a little too
close to Pokemon it is a fun game like
potentially stealing sorry borrowing
assets from Pokemon that's a fun game
then again if they were stealing
intellectual property from Nintendo hold
on okay nobody's been murdered so not
yet what what I just don't get the hype
it's a fun game some people not me but
some people have been accusing them of
using AI it's a fun game I know you hate
AI more than anything it's a very fun
game then again there's no hard evidence
that they used AI it's a fun game but
we're not totally certain it's a fun
game as long as you personally like it
there can't be anything to criticize
it's a fun game show me evidence it's a
fun game don't bring my wife into this
it's a fun we were on a vacation I had
food poisoning it's a fun game maybe
you're right maybe I'm just being a
hater oh wait looks like the developer
has dabbled in AI in the past it's a fun
game is that all you have to say you're
not a very fun game